Zach Roden if you had to flee the United
States permanently what country would
you go to and why other than Argentina
or Israel okay
that's interesting so I guess people are
saying no Argentina because that's where
I was born and that would be the sort of
natural place to return to if I had to
flee the United States people also
saying not Israel because I'm Jewish and
I guess they'd assume I'd go to Israel
because I'm Jewish I actually I have a
pretty specific answer to this based on
I'm going to limit it to places I've
been because until you go to a place you
don't really know what it might be like
to live there and even sometimes after
going on vacation you still don't know
assuming that I did not have sort of
passport and citizenship or residency
issues if I had to flee the United
States permanently and could never come
back and I was not to include Argentina
nor Israel as the question proposes I
would probably go to either Belgium or
Switzerland they're just I just like
both of those countries language you
know I guess if I was in the French part
of Switzerland or if I was in Brussels
where they speak French I'd get by and
my French would improve and I would be
ok I I think that that's probably where
I would go see if I was seeking some
sort of political asylum and I had to
get out of the country superfast oh you
go to Russia
yeah yeah I wouldn't not go to Russia
especially after the comments that I
made on the show but I would probably
choose somewhere like you know England
Ireland Australia somewhere where they
speak English because I wouldn't really
have to adapt to too much is there not
some place you would rather be because
just saying well I would only limit my
place to places where they speak English
you might not I'm not saying anything
about those places but you might not end
up in the place you like the most but if
I had some time to really plan it out
like I'm not you know a fugitive on the
run or anything like yet I think I would
choose a country where they don't
predominantly speak English because that
would give me all the reason in the
world to learn that so maybe I choose
something like France or Germany why
France or Germany as opposed to Italy or
Spain though yeah or Italy or Spain I
mean you would be yeah it would probably
be somewhere in you're in Europe when
you don't have a valuable languages
spoke
your feelings aren't that strong about
any particular country it sounds like
because you see I'm Dec I'm a
pure-blooded American who just wants to
stay here you because you seem
indifferent between drastically
different countries in Europe rather all
next to each other you know and share
some borders all right well Switzerland
or Belgium I think would be the places
for me or France or France would be
would be interesting as well